NATHAN ROGERS: Hi, and
welcome to Talks at Google.
My name's Nathan Rogers.
And today, I've the pleasure
of introducing one of my best
friends, Rose McAleese
to give a talk today.
So without further
ado, here is Rose.
ROSE McALEESE: Hi, my
name is Rose McAleese.
I'm a poet from
Seattle, Washington.
I'm just going to jump into it.
You want to divorce me.
Fine.
You wish to divorce me.
[DERISIVE LAUGH] You silly crow,
wingspan too short of raven,
you foolish king, if
it was not for me,
you would have no hunger
for demise or conquer,
crave the flesh of another.
I, your lady, no chambermaid,
rest assure and barren bed
for you, sit waiting past
midnight's croning moan.
Your robes are washed
daily by these hands.
Stone, cold water, rinse.
Make absence of any
bloodshed, I, your wife,
clean up all your messes.
You play no judgment on such
rash decisions as these.
No marks are made in your honor.
This.
Divorce?
You've wandered
too far, my dear.
Coward, I'm calling
you for a coward.
Coward, no hollow, no
backbone to aspire.
Where will you go, Sire?
Oh, Macbeth, such
childish quarrels as these
push us back in our demand.
Who will shine your blade?
Iron the wrinkles out of
your half-hearted strategy.
It is the queen who
makes all the moves.
My scenarios unravel like chess.
And you are just a
pawn, oh my worship, you
are just a wooden pawn.
Names of former lovers
hang over the mantelpiece
that is my heart.
Men, not worthy of royals.
You are lucky enough
to be sacrificed
as a spark in your
potential, flint
in the sense of
you being my Lord.
Now, I know the women here
back their husbands are
victim to naive, and God
smack but I-- I play shadow.
I sit closely to
your heels, because I
Lady Macbeth made every
dagger a happy one.
Bash the ridiculous
notion of failure.
One must steal if
one is not given.
I vow no sleep will
be lost over this.
And I know from experience
all bloodshed can easily
be washed away.
Thanks.
Oh, I need water.
[APPLAUSE]
Oh, OK.
So I like doing that one first,
because it gets the nerves out,
and it scares people.
So then I can win you back
over as the talk goes.
So like I said, I'm
a poet, a spoken word
poet from Seattle, Washington.
A little back history about
myself-- I started doing poetry
'cause when I was
in seventh grade,
I had a great teacher by
the name of Miss Chestnut.
She realized that I was
a rebel without a cause,
like I really tried to
be a bad-- I can't cuss.
A bad butt, but I
couldn't be, because I
was just like I had
no reason to be mad.
So, of course, when you
have no reason to be mad,
and you're seven years old,
you start writing poetry.
And that's pretty much
kind of where I started,
and then I became a spoken
word artist slowly over time.
And then as time
progressed, I realized
that I really love teaching.
And so I started being
a teaching artist,
which is kind of what I do now.
And then I guess,
almost two years ago, I
got my first book published.
You can like buy it now.
You can buy here later,
which is exciting.
It's really weird to be like,
I have a published book.
And so, yeah, I've
just kind of been
a poet and everything
and whatnot.
I was super nervous about this
talk for some weird reason.
I was watching all of
the other Google talks.
And I've noticed that you know,
there's people like Tina Fey
and like Lady Gaga,
who've all been here.
And so it was like, oh, OK,
I'm neither of those people.
I don't know what
I'm going to do.
So my father, god bless
his soul-- he's not dead.
I don't know I just said that.
He's alive and well.
Anyway, my father told me start
talking about what you love
and how passionate you are.
People will be
able to read that.
And whenever I get nervous, I'm
just going to jump into a poem.
So if I start doing something
or anything, just go with it.
OK?
So like I said, I'm
a teaching artist.
And the poem, I just
did was a persona poem
about Lady Macbeth.
I'm a huge Shakespearean nerd.
I fell in love with Shakespeare
when I was about 13 years old,
which was kind of just
disturbing to my parents.
But they were just like,
whatever, at least she's
reading.
Let her be all mournful
and semi-teenage angst,
depressed or whatever it was.
So I started doing that.
And then I got into
acting and realized
that poetry and spoken word
is basically like acting,
but you get to write
your own lines.
And so I started becoming
a teaching artist.
And in schools, it's really
hard to teach middle schoolers
and high school kids poetry.
They're like what do I need to
know about a dead white guy,
pretty much, which is true,
but also you can make your own
and revamp it.
Thank God for people like
Jack Kerouac and Angela Davis
and all these people who've kind
of like reinvented it and made
it their own and
everything, which
is so much fun with
slam poetry because it's
a mixture of beatniks, hip
hop, rap and all that jazz.
So that poem was
written from a writing
prompt that I came
up with my kids,
where I asked them to
take a fictional character
from either movie,
a play or a book.
And they had to
write a monologue
to get on a reality TV show.
So that was Lady
Beth's monologue
to get on the "Bad Girls Club."
I don't know if you guys
know the "Bad Girls Club,"
but it's a show
on Oxygen Channel.
Oh my god, you need to
watch the "Bad Girls Club" !
It is the best
piece of feminism.
Just kidding.
It's not.
Basically, they take
a bunch of girls
put them in a house with
alcohol and Daddy issues
and just let them
roam the world.
And they fight each other.
So let's be honest, Lady Macbeth
would make it on that show,
and she'd be great.
You should watch it.
It's such a great
guilty pleasure.
What else?
So, yeah, that's one
of the pieces I did,
It's also in my
book, which I have.
I want to show it.
Where is it?
I want to get it.
Sorry!
I should have had
my props ready.
I'm running offscreen.
This is going to be crazy.
I still can't get over this.
Like, I first got in my house
one day, and there it was.
And some guy named Tom
Robbins read it and liked it.
And so did Rachel
[? McKibbens ?]
and [INAUDIBLE].
I'm going to read one
more piece from this book.
I'll read a bunch of pieces,
but I really like this piece.
So I grew up with a very-- oh!
Someone walking in.
Hi.
I grew up with a very, very
Irish father, super Irish.
Also, a fun fact
about this book,
I wrote it when I was single.
Can't believe that
I a boyfriend now,
because if you
read this book, you
would be like why
would you date her?
So, sorry for the
guy who dates me.
This poem is called "Why
I Don't Write Love Poems."
And it starts out with a
quote from a smart man named
Charles McAleese, called "He
Says People are no Damn Good,
and Men Are Worse."
I've come to the
conclusion that I'm not
made for love, that feelings are
just tightly wound compasses,
trying to make it home
after a long night.
Romance is a store
brand laundry detergent
we use to wash away our naive.
Why do we love love?
Love clearly hates us.
I don't trust men who
know my middle name.
can charm my father
or drink like him either.
I don't trust men who smile too
big, whose best traits are all
physical.
I don't trust pretty
boys with nice eyes.
I don't trust guys who ask,
if you can't have children,
why do I need to wear a condom?
Well, first, you
need to leave me
with a mouth of rusty nails
and a clinic phone number.
One led me to believe that I
can save fish from drowning.
That man gave me a hammer and
told me to fix my own problems.
White Boy called me
intimidating, too much.
Lover-- not the
same shade as me,
reassures his mother
I was just a friend.
Boy told me we would work out,
because he didn't want children
either, because he made
sure to call me a dead end
before he left.
There is a pattern.
I love like my body, barren.
Now men who say I'm too strong
need to be men about it.
I mean handle your shit,
make more eye contact,
speak more loudly
and clearly when
you are walking away from me.
I will use this as
experience to hold it
against the next
pretty sucker who
marches his pretty
little face my way.
Pray for him, birds.
Let's hope that
one gets out alive.
Alert the others
that I lust like war.
I know how to snap next, swallow
nails, and flirt like Medusa.
Be forewarned.
I'm a maneater who is
developing serious hunger pains.
I do not need to say
or believe a thing.
You are no blacksmith.
You are no lumberjack.
Everything you leave
is made out of sugar.
This will all crumble
with one lick.
Maybe it's my fault I
wear tap shoes to bed.
I like a good entrance,
and I hate silence.
I have a soft spot for hip bones
and I love with escape in mind.
Maybe it's my fault that
I care with too many keys,
that I stain every
lover with rust
because if I can't
be beautiful, I
make sure no one else
around me is either.
I'm not bitter.
I'm just being a man about it.
No kissing, not trapping
myself in situations
I can't charm my way out.
I take after my mother.
I'm also take after winter.
I'm so cold.
I promised to leave
quiet this time,
just leave a sweaty palm
print on your door handle.
Boys, how can you not love a
girl with a good exit strategy.
Thank you.
So yay!
Cue cards!
Where's my cue cards?
I need those.
So the thing I really love
about poetry in particular
is that it's just such
a great way to express.
Usually people always
think that like with poetry
it either needs to rhyme or
needs to be this or that one,
when in all honesty, it
can be whatever you want.
It really can surely
come from anywhere
of sensitive inspiration.
One of the things I really
wanted to talk about
is this whole concept of
digital versus analog.
So me as a writer and
me as like a poet,
which is kind of a dying art,
or like, people are always like,
oh!
When they find out
I'm a poet, they
ask me like three questions.
First one is where
can I read your stuff?
I hate that question.
Because this was like
before I became published.
I was just like you're going
to hear it at a poetry slam.
And then the second one
is why are you a poet,
which I don't think
I need to explain it.
It just kind of happened.
And then the third
and final one is, so
what do you do for money?
Right?
So I realized that that's like
a really difficult thing to do.
Let's be honest.
We all want money.
We all want to get paid
for our art and everything.
But it's a sacrifice
that you make,
because you just love doing it.
So, as a writer,
I always am told
that I am like a crazy
person, because I
have to physically
write down every poem.
I can't just type it.
I have a very, very severe
and special form of dyslexia,
where I can't see vowels at all.
It's a very strange
form of dyslexia.
It's very rare.
So for me, when I write, it's
kind in this special language
that no one else
can really read,
because it's all
chicken scratch.
And like there's no
vowels in my words
pretty much, which I
used to worry about,
like so people are always
like why do you keep a diary?
What if you lose it?
It's like good luck
trying to read it.
There's that episode of Doug.
I don't know if anyone
remembers that show, Doug,
where Doug loses his journal.
And his arch nemesis,
Roger finds i.
And he's worried that
Roger's going to read it.
And Roger gives it back to him.
And he's like it's
chicken scratch.
You're able to read this.
And it's like, ah man, that just
made me feel so much better.
So for me, it's all
about the concept
that, like, when you're
stuck in a situation
or you find yourself in
front of the computer,
I always find myself
procrastinating more.
Like I find myself
so highly distracted
by everything and anything.
You know, all of a
sudden, I'm on Twitter.
All of a sudden,
I'm on Facebook.
All of a sudden, I'm
googling myself, whatever.
But when you have
a piece of paper,
you just kind of
forget how epically
organic that is, to literally
see the word on the page, just
pressed and archived for
your own personal advantage.
And I realize in
this day and age,
why keep a journal if no
one's going to read it.
But that's the thing
is you need to keep
a journal because no
one's going to read it.
I know this is like the
generation where you literally
put up, like, I had
the best tuna fish
sandwich ever on Twitter, right?
But not everyone
needs to know that.
I'm sorry, that stuff
always bothers me.
You need to tell people I'm
going to talk at Google.
That's the stuff they
like on Facebook.
But so my whole
thing is that you
have to go back to the page.
It's really difficult
and really hard.
And as a poet, you
go back to the page,
and then you kind of bring
it back to the stage.
That was so cheesy,
but really epic.
So with that I'll
give you another poem.
See?
I got all nervous, and then
I'm going to do a poem.
And then I'm not going
to be nervous anymore.
It's going great.
This is a good
choice of an outfit.
I went through like three
different choices today.
And I just think this one's
really epic and awesome.
[? Uniglo, ?] you
should do my wardrobe.
That was a really bad shout out.
That was fun.
Here's a poem.
One in a million.
That's how many people have your
reading disability, Roseanne.
One in a million.
That's what the
well-paid doctor told me.
But don't worry, he
said, you're not alone.
Wait, hold up.
One in a million
and I'm not alone?
That make as much
sense as this mumble
jumble they call an alphabet.
A-E-I-O-U and sometimes Y. See?
I didn't know these
letters were special,
and that these letters were
going to make me special.
But I can't recognize vowels.
And those little perks like to
play word games up, down, left,
right, vertical, cross the
page, like chess pieces
in a never-ending board game.
See, I don't know
what you learned.
But I learned E came before
I. If it didn't, then
they should have rearranged the
alphabet as I E F G T K X 7 4.
Ah, screw it.
You got me memorizing that
thing, like it's worth it.
I think spelling
altogether is preposterous.
Preposterous.
P-O-S-T-E-Z-R-N. Preposterous.
OK, so maybe my
spelling's a little off.
But have you ever
studied English spelling?
I mean, take the
word drunkenness.
D-R-U-N-K-E-N-N-E-S-S-.
A drunk came up
with the spelling.
I know this, because A, there's
not enough thought put into it,
and B, there's too many Ns.
And well, drunks never
know when to end.
There's an L in salmon.
Why the hell is
there an L in salmon?
Now you got my ears
[INAUDIBLE] riverbeds,
trying to hear that salmon.
And all I'm doing
is hitting walls.
And all I got to
say for it is damn.
A-E-I-O-U and sometimes
I ask myself Y.
See, bullies used to hold books
over my head yelling spell
it, Rose.
Spell it and you'll get it.
I was put in exile ever
from going near a library.
First, I blamed in on my pencil.
It seemed to be holding
everyone else's words just fine.
I cursed each one I picked
up, spelling it wrong again
and again and again.
Until the paper was nothing
but pinks marks and my eraser
had crumbled down like a
watered-down tumbleweed.
See, the brain is
like a window sill.
Outside, stage left,
there's an apple tree.
Replace those
apples with letters.
And when someone
approaches you and asks
you to spell something, you
can reach outside your window,
grab the letters
needed, and then look,
you have the word predictable.
Well, aren't you so smart.
See, my window is a lot
smaller and really dirty.
And my apple tree is
kind of dying and wilted
in the distance.
So when I do reach
for letters, I
bring up nothing but
sawdust and paint chips.
So do it.
Prick me again with
one of those Ns,
let me pour lemon
juice in my wounds.
Watch me shrivel
up like a slug I
used to torture on
boring summer day.
And when September
comes, I am nothing
but a ghostwriter
writing in invisible ink.
See my writing was fine.
The spelling was
being held against me.
I had great placements
for nouns, adverbs,
and I can braise
some veal-- I got
elegant adjective-- with ease.
I filled with tears
inside in spelling bee.
And this is my
apology to anyone who
says I can't be a poet because
I don't know how to spell.
Well, guess what?
You're wrong.
Because not only do I
write, I was a spit.
And I spit nothing but fire,
so call yourself cremated.
Yes, I do have my obstacles.
A-E-I-O-U, and sometimes
even Y. But as you can see,
they haven't stopped me yet.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
ROSE McALEESE: Whoo!
She goes off stage!
Wait, I have props.
I'm going to do a magic trick.
Can I come from the--
oh, I can't come up!
I was going to try come up.
This is Pippo.
He's famous.
Ah, man.
He's drunk.
He's a little drunk monkey.
I got Pippo when I
was three years old.
Him and I have the same
birthday, which is Halloween.
And he's, like, literally
my most prized possession,
which is so weird
for most people.
But he's the man.
He has to share a bed with me.
And he's awesome.
But the reason why I'm
talking about Pippo
is because-- so
this whole concept
of going back to the notebooks.
So I always have a notebook
with me, like everywhere I go.
Every jacket of mine has a
little tiny notebook and a pen.
I can't be somewhere
if I can't write.
You see artists all
the time that they're
doing imprints or
drawing or whatever
on a napkin or the
back of a ticket stub.
I'm that way.
I literally have millions and
millions of these notebooks.
And most notebooks
represent about six months.
And then I move on to the next
one and so on and so forth.
So one of the things
that I basically
wanted to have
this talk about is
that like when you're
stuck in a situation that's
extremely difficult
with dealing with life,
it's always good to go back to
the page and writing it out.
And one of my favorite things
to do is write out lists.
So I'm going to read
you guys some of my list
from my notebook, which
is kind of like not
my point, because my point is
to keep it in the notebook.
But let's just pretend you
guys are in my bedroom.
And I practiced this Google
Talk in my bedroom one too
many times.
He had to listen to it.
So these are things that
I believe to be true.
OK?
Pigeons don't die.
Has anyone seen a baby pigeon?
Exactly.
They don't die.
Pigeons have been here
since the beginning.
I also believe that I was
going to marry Sam Cooke.
Then I found out he died.
And then I told my mom I
was going to marry my dad.
And my mom was like [SNORT]
good luck with that.
So that's bad.
I think spelling is stupid.
The best moments are
never caught on film.
I met Dave Chapelle once.
No one believes me, because
I didn't Instagram it.
I think "Clueless"
and "Mean Girls"
are the funniest movies ever.
You cannot debate me on that.
I'm sorry.
I've had many arguments
with friends being like, no.
"Clueless" and "Mean Girls."
On Wednesdays, we wear pink.
Is today Wednesday?
No, it's not.
OK, never mind.
I also think that
Beyonce is a unicorn.
She's amazing.
I also believe that
writing things down
is better than typing them out.
I also believe that
the power of good art
and the power of bad art.
Here's my bucket list.
First of all, I hate
the word bucket list.
It just sounds so
stupid and dirty.
Like bucket is just
a dirty word to me.
So this is my to do list,
which sounds even dirtier, now
that you say it.
Like, "to do."
Anyways.
So this is what I want
to do for my to-do list.
I'd like to move out
of my roommate's house.
Fun fact, since I am a poet, I
live with this elderly couple.
They're great.
I call them Mom and Dad.
They're nice.
They're not freaked out that
I call them Mom and Dad,
because I'm been calling
them that my whole life.
Anyways.
OK.
I would like to
write a screenplay.
I would also like to find
out what Bill Murray says
at the end of "Lost
in Translation"
to Scarlett Johannsen.
I would like to find the
perfect voice for Pippo.
I want to do like a Lifetime
web series of just my life,
because I think I'm cool enough.
And Pippo needs a voice.
But I don't know
what he sounds like,
so I'm up for suggestions.
You can look at him
and examine him.
I think British, but I'm Irish.
So why are you British?
I don't know.
So if you can think
of a name for him--
I actually want to listen
to Dr. Dre's "Detox."
It's like Beyonce.
It's a unicorn.
I don't know if it's
actually going to come out.
I want to befriend a girl
named Becky really badly,
so I can be like "Becky,
look at her butt."
I also want to
find a baby pigeon.
I want to be on "SNL."
So here's my "SNL"
moment, you guys.
I'm going to use
this Google Talk.
Lorne Michaels, if you're
out there, or Maya Rudolph,
I really want to be on "SNL."
Like, it kind of
disgusting how badly
I want to be on this show.
So I realize in my "SNL"
-like working things out,
there are two types
of people in "SNL."
This all has to
do with something.
OK, I promise this will have
a good conclusion at the end.
I hope.
Anyways, two things
about "SNL" people.
You're either a
character person,
where you make up new
characters, like the Target
Lady or Debbie Downer, all that.
Or you're someone
who does impressions.
I don't think I
can do impressions.
But I have two impressions!
Can I test them out
for you on you guys?
Can I?
There are people in this
audience, I promise, YouTube.
OK, so here's my
two impressions.
OK?
So, Obama.
[EXHALES] I'm going to get here.
(DEEP VOICE) Sasha,
Malia, go to bed.
(NORMAL VOICE) OK.
Now here's my Yogi
Bear impression.
(DEEP VOICE) Sasha,
Malia, go to bed.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
ROSE McALEESE: They're
the same person!
Anyways, OK.
Sorry, that was my "SNL" moment.
Also, moving on.
So basically I'm working on
like nine different projects
right now that have nothing
to do with my art, which
really bums me out and
really makes me sad,
because I actually
have to do things
that I will pay my nonrent
to my nonroommates.
But every time I make a list,
I always feel like I'm writing,
that I'm an actual writer, that
I'm actually doing something
that matters, because
it impresses myself
and it impresses Pippo,
and at the end of the day,
it makes me happy.
So one of the last lists
I wrote is things I hate.
Dentists, bananas, snow,
split sinks-- you know,
when they have one
faucet for hot water
and one faucet for cold water.
I hate that.
Which one do you use?
Being told that I'm too much,
too passionate, too churned-up,
or too excited.
I hate flying.
I hate how easily
stressed I get.
I hate how no one experiences
paper cuts anymore,
because in this digital age,
no one reads books that often.
You know what I mean?
It's always on something.
This is the
generation-- actually,
you know what, that's
actually a good thing.
Why am I hating off a paper--
no one wants paper clips.
I think Google saved the paper
clip, if you think about it.
The paper cut, I mean.
Like you don't get
paper cuts anymore.
You just Google search things.
And I also hate buffering
on like Hulu videos.
Can someone fix that?
No one?
OK, never mind.
Anyways, so
basically my point is
just that when everything
comes down to it,
the paper and the
pen are literally
the most mightiest
things in the world.
I am in this really weird
purgatory stage in my life
where I don't know
exactly what I'm doing.
Like I can't even believe
that I'm here right now.
But I think it just has to do
with I literally write letters
to the universe.
And then I just kind of press
it together in my notebook
and hope that someday, someone
reads it, if not in the cosmos
or whatever.
So it's just like go
back to actual writing.
I mean picking up a pen
is such a heavy act,
but it does so much.
So now I'm nervous again.
So I'm going to do another poem.
This is easy.
Rappers don't really talk
between their songs, do they?
They just kind of go
into the next song.
They're horrible
public speakers.
I think rappers are
horrible public speakers.
That's a secret.
But then again, I
want to be a rapper.
I already have four
rap names-- Rose Gold,
Rosetta Stone, and
Rose Bowl, which
is like if I ever become
like a high rapper.
But I don't smoke weed.
So, never mind.
More poems.
[EXHALES]
James Brown steps on stage.
He is carved from
midnight's marble.
He turns to his right hand
man, Clyde Funky Drummer
Stubblefield and says, kick
a little, Clemen-clyde.
Clyde, bursting from
his love and joy, all
that is rhythm and blues,
beats the drums with such ease
like God told him to play like
he was God playing the drums.
The sound that came out
was pure, cold sweat.
It's flesh.
We're naked around the arena.
A classic in the making.
The record skips,
the record skips,
the record skips a few years,
and hip hop shows up late
but looks good.
Does not make eye contact
with anyone in the room,
afraid someone might notice.
Um, excuse me.
They're not from
around these parts.
See hip hop was given
all the hand-me-downs,
but learned to put swag
back in their stitches.
Took what's not theirs
and made it their own.
See, everything was
fine, until someone
noticed the similarities
there once was.
Hip hop.
You kicked a little too
much dust off those records.
Even Midas knows the price
you got to pay for the touch.
The samples are not free.
I would worry if I were
you, Mr. Biz Markie.
In 2004, Brian Burton took the
JZ Black Album and the Beatles
White Album and
made the Grey album.
EMI, record companies, all of
a sudden feeling very cheated,
decides to sue this nobody
for all that he's worth.
This plan backfires, and
they pulled this lover,
this fan of pure music
into the limelight for all
to love and admire.
The Beatles, angry about all
that has taken from them,
have a song called
"Revolution #9"
which is nine minutes of
remix, remix, remix, mastered
in sounds.
Andy Warhol can paint someone
else's photos and call it art.
He even took a soup
can to stop himself
from being a starving artist.
Shakespeare took the framework
of a tragic Italian love story
and slapped his name on it.
Disney had the audacity to take
you your loved fairy tales,
add some colors, re-animate
them, and walk to the bank,
because well, this
generation know
the best artists do not copy.
They steal.
And history is nothing
more than a 12-year boy
with a serious (MOCK
STUTTER) stuttering problem,
who's been told
one too many times
to learn from your mistakes.
It is one thing to pull
from your inspiration.
It is another thing to be
the Man's tracing paper.
As poets, as writers,
no, as humans, as humans,
we sample all the time.
Sample like ribcage.
Advice your
grandmother once gave
you are the weight of Atlas.
Nothing is holy.
Nothing is sacred.
However, she'll be recognized
and respected and thanked.
This evening, class,
Funky Drummer Stubblefield
is doing me an honor of playing
my outro, a sample of all
my favorite Kanye
West-- oop, sorry.
Pardon me-- Frankenstein tunes.
Clyde, whose own
original sound has
been copied on 100 different
songs, has yet to see a penny.
But for the record, he
wants nothing in return
but a simple thank you.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
ROSE McALEESE:
Shake that monkey.
That was inappropriate.
Never mind.
Anyway, so yeah, being a writer.
It's fun.
It's interesting.
It's been a very interesting
process, especially
with becoming a teaching artist.
I was horrible in school.
I absolutely hated school.
It was really difficult
for me, because I
had a reading disability.
And instead of trying
to actually have someone
to pull me aside, and
explain to me what happened,
they just threw
me in special ed,
and were just like we're going
to just-- she sinks or swims,
pretty much.
So I've been going
back into schools
and trying to help people
realize that everyone's special
and everyone's unique
in their own way.
And one of the writing
exercises that I
do with my kids,
first-off, is I tell
them to write a Pinky List.
And a Pinky List
is a list of things
that make you different
than the next person.
So, for instance,
on my Pinky List,
I would say like I'm
born on Halloween.
I have a fear of bananas.
My socks never match.
And just all the weird stuff.
There's so many-- why
can't I think of a
in single weird thing
about me right now.
But yeah, so basically,
one of things I do
is do a Pinky List, which
is a great writing exercise.
I love lists.
I think that they
literally break down
any situation or any problem you
have or face in everyday life.
And I guess in this
whole thing that I
want you guys to walk away
with is to just write.
Journal out just to basically
just leave it on the page.
I mean, I can't
stress that enough.
It's just so epically
awesome, and it's really hard
to just leave in your head.
It just hurts.
It really does.
You just have to put it on
the page and figure it out.
I also would like
to give you guys
some writing prompts,
because I'm big on that.
So one of them is to
make a Pinky List.
You guys have
homework, and you're
going to have to submit it to
me on Twitter in 140 characters
or less.
So one of the ones I
have is the Pinky List.
Another one that I have,
one of y favorite writing
prompts that I do with
my high school kids
is "Things My Ex
Would Have Said."
They love that one.
I don't know.
But kids are-- they love
the anti-love poems.
Like screw you,
Dante or whatever.
Then the other one is "Tell
Me About the Ride Home," which
actually I kind of stole that
from a famous hero of mine,
Seamus Heaney, RIP.
And so, yeah, that's
some writing prompts.
So you guys can go with.
So I'm going to
do one more poem.
And then you guys
are free to go back
to your awesome Googleness.
By the way, I have a
question about Google.
When you are like on the
interweb, are you Google-able?
Like I tell people
this all time,
like, oh, they're like
where can I find you?
And I'm like, oh,
I'm Google-able.
That's not a good word.
You guys have got to think of
something else to think of.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Google me.
ROSE McALEESE: Oh!
Google me.
That's stupid.
Why didn't I just think of that?
Someone make a
hashtag of Google me.
That was a dumb question.
OK.
This is it.
I'm going to take
up a lot of space.
So thank you for coming.
This is a huge honor
and not as scary
as I thought it was going to be.
This has been fun.
I hope you enjoyed yourself.
If not, lie to me.
OK?
Thanks.
What is the first
line of this poem?
See, this is the other
thing about poetry.
It does not need to be
perfect and crafted,
and sound like you went
to college to write it.
Because I didn't go to college.
School of Hard Knocks.
Anyway, OK.
I should do a football tag.
What do they do?
They say their name and
whatever school they went to.
I'm going to do
that. (DEEP VOICE)
Rose McAleese, School of
Hard Knocks, Sea Hawks.
I shouldn't say that.
We're in San Francisco.
Not San Francisco.
We're safe in this area.
Google's safe.
Sea Hawk fans here?
Any?
AUDIENCE: Whoo!
ROSE McALEESE: Yay!
There's like two of your guys.
OK, so this is the last poem.
With a face more judgmental
than a Rorschach,
he says, that's funny.
You don't dance
like a white girl.
Now before I can apply
to his ignorant comment,
my beloved drunken friend
reassures him (TIPSY VOICE)
well, that is because
Rose is a unicorn!
Sha sha sha sha!
Where are my shoes?
I do not spill drinks when
I dance, because, well, I
don't drink.
And also I need my
hands always to be free.
I do not chase boys.
I run in place.
I'm a tall glass
of water that likes
to get loose-limbed,
like liquid.
Give me your marble!
Give me your hard wood!
Give me your bar top, even
roof of moving vehicle
to truly tell you how my feet
met floor a long time ago.
And I dare not separate
the three of them.
I don't even need
music to dance,
because that way I
can never be off beat.
In middle school, I
was an awkward bag
of bones and untalented ticks.
Some might say a skinny
excuse, a spastic.
My friends used to
threaten me by saying,
Rose, if you can't dance,
we can't be friends.
This scared me straight.
But not straight enough I
couldn't learn how to bend.
Since then, I have been
sweating for unreasons
unknown to the masses.
And it's because my body
thinks the Rapture is coming.
And I need to produce holy
water to save me and my dance
partner.
People on average usually
notice three things about me.
One, she talks a lot.
And if she's not
talking, I'm smiling.
And if I'm not
smiling, I'm dancing.
And for me,
dancing's just my way
of smiling through
a conversation.
We don't even need
to talk to get along,
just the heavy amount
of body language.
And everyone is fluent in that.
If you don't leave
me, well, hey.
One of us is lying
and it isn't me,
because well, I don't
take anything lying down.
Baby!
I can make my hips tick faster
than any maternal clock.
I can make your head ring
like a jewelry store.
Ay, yo, yo.
You hungry?
Try my salsa.
And may cause your girlfriend
a serious heartburn.
I am a party baby.
I will make you cry and like it.
I'm also a natural-born ham.
That's why I'm cutting
this rug like a butcher.
Now, I have
ballrooms in my belly
and a funky ruckus
in my armpits.
But sometimes, I'm not
good with my words.
So I have this face
where, like, when
I'm really embarrassed--
like I'm kind of probably
doing it right now, my face
turns bright red, which is just
so bad, it's really obnoxious.
Then I have this
yoga position where
I can put my food in my mouth.
But my spine thinks otherwise.
The only time my body
seems to align perfectly
is when I'm on this very stage.
And the only time I've ever
allow myself to feel beautiful
is when I'm dancing.
We make gods when we dance.
But dancing has
never been a God.
So there's no need
for your judgment day.
You better rock, span,
spit, stripe your dress
from however you please.
Everyone was meant
to move like this.
Now, the ignorant ink
blot of the man at the bar
is now lost for words.
I begin to turn away to
dance this moment off.
He stops me and
asks if he can join.
And I said, oh
sweetie, that's cute.
But I think it's best
that you just back, relax,
turn my body into a hashtag.
Tweet about this
for your safety.
And I'll truly show you how a
unicorn human being breaks it
down.
Thanks, guys.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
ROSE McALEESE: Whoo!
We out of here, Pippo!
Oh, we're going
to take questions.
Oh, I didn't know it was that.
Does anyone have a question?
This is cool.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Canadian or Russian?
ROSE McALEESE: [LAUGHS] Yeah!
I like it.
Someone suggested that Pippo
should be a Canadian accent.
How do you feel about that?
AUDIENCE: Or Russian.
ROSE McALEESE: Or Russian.
He could be Russian.
I have this theory.
I wrote a list once.
I do social media
as a form of payment
sometimes, which is so funny.
I get paid to Tweet.
And one of the lists
I came up with,
because I was so
frustrated with the job,
was Things Pippo is Famous For.
He's a famous jewel thief.
He is actually the original
member in the Beatles.
He is also what Sherlock
Holmes was based on.
He is Watson and Sherlock.
Yeah, he's a pretty great guy.
He used to have
these red overalls,
but I lost them in
a movie theater.
I lost them watching
the movie "Beethoven,"
if anyone remembers
that-- the dog.
His hands are also Velcro.
But he's getting old.
Oops, story.
He's fine.
Look, he's so regal.
Anyway.
Oh my god, you have a question!
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I have two questions.
ROSE McALEESE: OK.
AUDIENCE: One is what
grades do you teach?
ROSE McALEESE: Oh, OK.
Mostly high school.
I don't really do well
in middle schools,
because I feel like I didn't
do well in middle school.
I had a lot of fun
in high school.
Fun fact.
The man who introduced
me, Nathan, we
went to middle school
and high school together.
We were both nominated
Most School Spirited.
So that was kind of
me in high school.
I was just this weirdo.
So I teach 9th
through 12th grade.
But I really love teaching
freshman, because they just
seem the most awkward-est.
If you can't tell,
I'm like a jellyfish
caught in a blender.
I don't know what to do
with myself half the time.
AUDIENCE: I have an
interview question.
ROSE McALEESE: You have
a interview question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
ROSE McALEESE: Yeah.
Wait.
Oh my god, so OK, I did
research on you guys
by watching this movie
called "The Internship."
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
ROSE McALEESE: Right?
And then the Google.
Here's the thing.
When they asked the
question about the blender,
the immediate thing
I thought of was
the blender will eventually die.
So you just chill out.
And that's exactly what
they do in the movie.
So where's my
internship, Google?
I answered the question.
I bet, Pippo's probably going
to get a job offer and me.
Whatever.
He's talking smack right now.
What other questions do they ask
you at Google for a interview?
Is it just that, the
only hypothetical one.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
ROSE McALEESE: I'm going to
talk to the HR department.
I'm going to come up with some
weird questions for you guys.
Like, what reality show
would you try out for?
Which Kardashian do you
think is your spirit animal?
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
ROSE McALEESE: Things like that.
Which I think tell a lot about
a person, like I'm a Khloe!
Makes sense.
AUDIENCE: All right.
I'll ask my second
question then.
ROSE McALEESE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: If I can remember it.
So, with your
reading disability,
how do you go from a
chicken scratch to a book?
ROSE McALEESE: So think god.
Oh my god, I have a great
editor who's also my roommate.
My mother.
I love Kathy Cain.
But yeah, no, I had a
really great editor.
And my publisher-- so a
funny thing about my book
is that I made a
paper copy of my book.
And I hid them in bookstores.
And my publisher stumbled
across it and was
like, wow, this is really cool.
I actually know this girl.
And this publisher was actually
a family friend of mine.
And she was like I didn't know
you wanted to publish a book so
let's publish a book.
So literally, it's lots of
editors and things like that.
And I do a lot of
exercises and stuff
that have helped me
with my disability.
It used to be way worse.
Like in fifth grade, I
had the reading level
of a kindergartner.
Now I have the reading
level of a fifth grader.
So it's great.
I love those "Lemony
Snicket" books.
Man, they really understand me.
Except they have really
big words in that book.
But yeah, now I
just have an editor.
And as much as I hate
writing on a computer,
spell check is a lot of fun.
But if you're dyslexic,
there's a lot of loopholes.
Like I can write the word "I,"
when I really mean myself.
I can write this eye
when I mean this I.
And spell check
won't correct it.
There needs to be a grammar
check, especially on Twitter.
The your and you're.
Oh, I hate that.
Or there and their.
Remember DOL?
They don't teach that
in schools anymore?
Is that it?
Am I good to-- You
have a question?
AUDIENCE: So you're perfectly
happy for your spelling
to be corrected.
You don't feel like
that it loses something?
ROSE McALEESE:
No, I don't really
mind when people
correct my spelling.
I bet my friends and my family
and friends and my boyfriend
can tell you I do these
idiosyncricities or something
like that.
I also have a mush mouth.
So I grew up with
an Irish father,
where I had an accent
when I was little.
And because of that, I feel
like I can't say certain words
correctly, which on top
of a reason disability,
just makes me like a
really great comic strip.
But I don't have an issue
with people correcting me
with spelling.
I kind of have more
of an issue when
people correct when I
pronounce things wrong.
Like what's that word I say?
PO-tin-ate.
Potinate.
But it's just potent.
For some reason, I want
the word to be potinate.
Or upstairges
instead of upstairs.
I can't say that.
Yeah, there's a lot of
weird things I say wrong.
Like fa-SHE-shis.
That's not the word.
I have real trouble
with speaking.
English is hard.
GAIR-age.
And I say that, like
a parking garage.
That's really hard.
Oh, the letter before I
in the alphabet, is HAIH.
It will always be haich.
But there are ones that
I got rid of. [INAUDIBLE]
feel like that one.
But I used to make fun
of my dad and family
for saying PRIHV-a-cy,
instead of PRI-va-cy.
But I say it sometimes,
and that one's just ugly.
So you can correct
me on that one.
But no, I have no issue with
people correcting my spelling.
Do it.
Please.
It's bad.
Anyway.
Like, why is there
a D in Wednesday?
OK, sorry.
I'm done.
We should leave.
Thanks, guys!
I hope you enjoyed.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]